[موسيقى]
قتل سبعه اشخاص واصيب سته عشر اخرون بجروح
بينهم عدد من العاملين في قناه العربيه
مكاتب العربيه الواقعه في حي المنصور في
العاصمه العراقيه تتعرض لاول مره منذ
تاسيسها في بغداد لهجوم بسياره مفخخه
11 شهيدا صحفيا خسرهم مكتب قناه العربيه
في العراق ففي الثامن عشر من مارس عام
2004 خسر مكتب العربيه في العراق اول
شهيدين وهما المراسل علي الخطيب والمصور
الذي كان يرافقه علي عبد العزيز بعد ان
فتحت القوات الامريكيه النار عليهما
حددت اوصاف القوات الموجوده على ارض
العراق جواد كاظم العربيه بغداد
الصحفيون في العراق عرضه للاعتداء اليوم
كان موعد المراسل العربيه زميل جواد كاظم
ليواجهه الارهاب
كل انسان
عنده علاقه
بلحظه الموت قت
ل اصيب 19 اخرون بجروح بينهما عدد من
العاملين في قناه العربيه في انفجار سياره
مفخخه
حيث تحولت المدن وشوارع العراقيه
[موسيقى]
الى
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام اينما كنتم والى
لقاء اخر وضعيف وحوار خسرت قناه العربيه
مرسلتها في العراق الزميله اطوار بهجت
اضافه الى زميلين اخرين هما المصور عدنان
خير الله ومهندس الصوت خالد محمود
[موسيقى]